Watsonville California is an
agricultural community we have 98
percent of our students are Latino and
about 90 percent of our students speak
Spanish as their first language teachers
cannot do their job alone they need to
have resources because every class that
they receive which is usually between 25
and 30 has a variety of learners in that
classroom so teachers use a wide variety
of tech tools in their classrooms and
Khan Academy is one of those tools
because it allows for differentiation
amongst the learners
miss koto takes teaching as a skill and
turns it into an art form
this year was amazing with learn storm I
had a group of students they couldn't
add subtract multiply or divide
fractions they avoided it at all costs
but since it was an assignment they
would try it and they would eventually
do much better and what was amazing was
that the lower achieving students were
able to see that they were part of
something huge they were able to
contribute and that I thought boosted
their self-confidence their self-esteem
and I didn't realize that would happen
after doing some storm learned storm
really made me realize how much you can
grow and just a short amount of time and
if you put that same amount of effort
you can grow even more I'm impressed
and many of you guys are getting it
right some of you guys are getting stuck
I will show you where you're getting
stuck and I'd love that you're not
giving up all of our classmates worked
so well together and it really showed
that we really did win as a team it was
really breathtaking because I think her
goal was just to reach level 12 and then
we ended up reaching Mike level 36 we
completed I think 8080 assignments first
thing in the morning I had everybody
start doing some mastery challenges and
after I took role I said okay guys let's
look at the the progress tracker and it
just kept going up the students loved it
the growth mindset activities we watched
one every single week as a group and
they would share their ideas with their
partners I can see towards the end of
the year they don't give up they work
harder I keep going and keep growing
means to push your limits and to even if
you make a mistake
learn from them and keep growing with
your learning thinking about learn storm
and the students going to college almost
makes me want to cry because I think at
the beginning so many of the students
felt I just can't do it but because they
were able to do learn storm and their
skills are so much higher now they know
that they can keep going and keep
growing and not
we'll stand in their way
[Music]